y raúl han sido 48 horas frenéticas
boris johnson a finalmente ha aceptado
que su tiempo como primer ministro ha
terminado en dos semanas completaría
tres años como premier británico ha
dicho en un discurso
conciso de unos seis minutos que es hora
de marcharse y entonces ha dicho cuales
a su juicio son sus principales logros
el break sí por supuesto para eso fue
elegido es uno de sus grandes logros
pero recordemos que ahora el reino unido
está en una disputa legal con la unión
europea por el protocolo de irlanda del
norte porque el reino unido se niega a
reconocer justamente ese acuerdo
comercial también es bien importante
boris johnson ha dicho que el reino
unido ha logrado la tasa de vacunación
contra el jove y 19 más rápida y más
alta de toda europa ha insistido en la
importancia de que el nuevo líder del
partido conservador el nuevo primer
ministro británico continúe con esa
política de estado y es seguir apoyando
a ucrania
la guerra contra rusia ha insistido
boris johnson durante estos meses desde
que inició esa invasión en la
importancia de la unidad de europa
frente a putin y de la otan y ha dicho
ha tenido la oportunidad de dar un
mensaje a los ucranianos y decirles que
el reino unido continuará con ellos
dándoles todo el apoyo que pueda y
recordemos que este es uno de los
grandes financiadores de las armas de
ucrania también boris johnson ha
resaltado que desafortunadamente no tuvo
la oportunidad de cumplir con su agenda
la que se había fijado para los próximos
años pero lo cierto es que el país el de
demanda que le había demandado que
hiciera modificaciones para poder
sortear el la crisis de la vida por la
inflación y el aumento en los precios de
los alimentos que sí es una tendencia
mundial pero también los precios por
ejemplo de la energía del agua y de los
alimentos en este país estaban
disparados ha tenido johnson también la
oportunidad de agradecer a su familia
especialmente a su esposa carbide a sus
dos niños su esposa también está
salpicada por muchos de sus scandal
entre ellos por el partido por el que
también fue multada por la policía
también luisa mencionabas un punto muy
importante por supuesto el break si
digamos el logro mayor que fueron estos
casi tres años de johnson en el poder
pero todavía queda algo pendiente y es
este protocolo con irlanda del norte que
ha tenido fricción entre el bloque
comunitario y reino unido- que va a
pasar y como deja digamos boris johnson
este precisamente este punto del proxy
con el protocolo irlanda del norte y qué
retos tendría digamos quien sea el
próximo primer ministro para poder
solucionar este tema
aquí
sí boris johnson entrega entregará en
algunos meses en el otoño se prevé que
saldrá finalmente hasta que haya un
sucesor un nuevo primer ministro deja
una lista de urgentes y de pendientes en
esta lista de urgentes está resolver esa
disputa comercial cada vez más fuerte
con la unión europea recordemos que
cuando este país salió de esa comunidad
para que la región de irlanda del norte
no volviera a tener los problemas que
tuvo por el conflicto tras el acuerdo de
paz de 1998 esa región irlanda del norte
se mantiene dentro del mercado único y
el sistema aduanero de la unión europea
lo que está generando
traumatismos para por ejemplo llevar
alimentos por ello el reino unido ha
decidido desconocer ese mecanismo legal
y está prácticamente
poniendo sobre la mesa un una guerra que
podría convertirse comercial con la
unión europea así que el reino unido ha
decidido presentar una legislación para
desconocer partes de ese protocolo de
irlanda
que sin lugar a dudas es desconocer el
protocolo o break si es desconocer el
acuerdo break sit y violar un acuerdo
comercial así que ha iniciado por
supuesto esa disputa fuertísima entre
londres y bruselas y como lo vimos en el
break si esa situación puede ser muy
larga y muy compleja tendremos que ver
cuál es la postura del nuevo primer
ministro sobre la unión europea algunos
conservadores son más europeístas y
otros no si es elegido alguien que tenga
el mismo carácter y el mismo y la misma
idea de boris johnson sobre la unión
europea podrían ser días días bien bien
complejos pero también raúl es
importante destacar lo que mencionas por
el johnson se mantendrá en el poder o
esté en el cargo porque la autoridad
está muy golpeada hasta hasta que se
elija a su sucesor en la conferencia
anual del partido que puede ser en
septiembre o en octubre pero los
diputados de su partido no están
contentos porque quieren que se vaya así
que no sería extraño que este proceso
para elegir al primer ministro sea
incluso mucho rápido de lo que hemos
visto hasta el momento